You have beautiful hands.
You are quite unused to physical labor, no?
War changes everything.
The Kaiser remains of great symbolic importance to the German people.
You'll address him as "Sir" and you will speak only when spoken to...
...and all discussion of politics is forbidden.
You are to take immediate command of his military guard.
British Secret Service have an agent in the area.
Could be a kidnap attempt, most likely an assassination.
If anything happens to him, Captain, you'll be shot.
Captain, there's a British spy after me.
You'll be quite safe, Your Highness
My name is Stefan, I was wondering what yours was.
Mieke de Jong.
Be careful, nobody is safe.
Can an officer have a loyalty to anything greater than his country?
Marry me, Mieke, now, today.
He was going to turn you over to the Gestapo.
Mieke, trust me!